Our email subscriber Tristan T. asked me
the question, "What books other than
copywriting books would you recommend?"
I'm going to give you one great
recommendation. That is Red Rising. This
is a fiction novel that I've read the
entire series, all six books right now,
which is over like 6,000 pages worth of
reading on just this book, and I highly
recommend this because the storytelling
and the pacing and the character
development and all that stuff is
incredible for you writing copy,
especially if you are an email
copywriter and you tell stories in your
emails. Instead of studying a bunch of
other email copywriters who are telling
the same stories in the same styles, go
study fiction novelists, number one
best-selling authors on how they tell
stories so you can inject that into your
copy. That is a big secret tactic to
copywriting is stealing other industry
styles and injecting it into your
industry. Highly recommend Red Rising,
great book.